>>Presenter: Welcome everybody. My name is
Thor Mitchell, I am Product Manager for the
Google Maps API. Welcome to Google IO. I hope
you're enjoying it so far. We have today a
bunch of The Geo API luminaries on stage;
here to give you a brief overview of the kind
of things we're doing right now, and answer
questions you might have that have been festering
in your brain for the last year. Um, so let
me just do a quick round of introductions.
Um this is Ben. Ben is the techno manager
for the Maps API.
>>Ben: Hey everyone. I'm the engineering manager
for the Maps API. I work in Sydney.
>>Bart: I'm Bart Locanthi, I'm in Mountainview.
I work on the um, Maps Data API and also My
Maps.
>>Matt: Hi, my name is Matt and I'm a product
manager in Mountainview, working on the Data
Maps API team
>>Peter: I'm Peter Birch, I'm Product Manager
for Google Earth API as well as the rest of
the Google Earth family.
>>Thatcher: Hi, I'm Thatcher Ulrich. I am
the Tech lead of the Earth API, [coughs] excuse
me, and plug in.
>>Thor: Great, so what we thought we'd do
is, um, just take a couple of minutes each
to talk about, um recent developments or developments
in these various APIs over the last year and
just kind of remind some of you where we're
at and uh, and then we'll open it up to questions.
So on the subject of the Maps API, I'm not
sure how many of you were in our session that
we finished just 15 minutes ago. Um, but you'll
uh, you may not have heard that, as some of
you may be aware we have a couple of different
Map APIs. Uh we have the V2 JavaScript’s
Maps API, which is the most heavily used Maps
API and often the one that people think of
when you hear someone saying Maps API, and
that's been around for almost five years now.
It's a very popular used, actively used on
over 350,000 websites worldwide. At this time
last year at Google IO we launched a new JavaScript’s
Maps API, the Maps API V3, which is primarily
motivated by desire to cater better to the
sort of new breed of mobile web-enabled devices
like the iPhone and the Android and such like.
And that launched in Labs at Google IO last
year. And over the course of the last year,
we've been gradually adding more and more
features to that API and trying to build it
up to be a credible successor to the Maps
API V2. So, uh we are very happy to announce
just an hour ago, that the Maps API V3 is
graduating from Google Code Labs today and
from here on will be the principle Google
Maps JavaScript’s API. And you'll find that
all of the Maps API-related content at this
year's Google IO is focused on the Maps API
V3.
>>Matt: Yeah, so on the Maps Data API side
we announced the API last year at Where 2.0
and the idea behind the API, if you're not
familiar with it is that you can store geographic
content on Google's clouds so it can be kind
of a pain when your, when you want to make
a maps mash up to run your own server, or
you're on geospatial database and so the idea
is you should be able to focus on just creating
like a really cool client you know mash up
and we'll take care of the storage and hosting
and bandwidth issues for you. Um, so this
was launched last year, and then one of the
things that we were pretty excited about,
we launched just at the end of the year was
Search. So that, you know it's one thing to
just be able to just upload geographic content
to the cloud and then get it back and update
it, but you also often want to be able to
search over it. So, now you should be able
to upload, say you know 4,000 hotels for example,
in the United States and then do both spatial
and attribute queries on it. So you can say,
you know, give me all of the hotels within
20 miles of San Francisco, and I want only
the ones that have a pool and Wi-Fi. So you
can sort of decide what attributes, they're
just custom attributes, you can add to features,
then you can control what you get back there.
And, then we also added map access controls,
so you can say exactly, sort of who has access
to your map. Do you want it to be private
or public or open to the world? Share it just
with specific collaborators? And, uh, you
can also think of this API as basically giving
you programmatic access to Google My Maps.
So you can, if you want to write like a My
Maps client on a mobile phone for example,
you can basically use it to create and update
and retrieve Google My Maps.
>>Peter: So, it's been a pretty exciting year
for us for Earth API. This is our second year
anniversary of when we announced it. Last
couple of years we've been spending a lot
of time working on, you know general stability,
performance, platforms getting onto more browsers,
more OS's. Probably the most interesting recent
development is that Google itself has become
one of the largest Maps, Earth API user with
the introduction of the Earth View in our
maps. If you go to Google Maps, right now,
you actually click on an Earth button, it
brings up, you know, an earth view right there.
You can switch back and forth between other
views. You can do the things that you would
normally do in Google Maps, but now immediately
switch over and get an interactive high-performance
fluid 3-D view as well. That's using all of
our public APIs. That's using the same plug
in, the same JavaScript, everything like that.
That's basically the product that we built
for you guys two years ago and have been,
and continuing to develop. But now, it's actually,
you know, an integral part of one of our core
properties and I think that's a testament
to sort of, how we've progressed and, and
this, you know how that has grown as a platform.
Um, I'm not going to talk a lot about what's
coming up next because I don't want to steal
Josh's thunder, who's actually back in the
back there. And tomorrow, at 2:15 there's
going to be a talk that he and Mano, who's
in front here, are going to talk a little
bit about Earth API and KML and kind of what's
new. So I'm not going to tell you anything.
So you go to that talk, tomorrow at 2:15.
The one thing I will steal from their thunder
a little bit, is one of the exciting things
has been just over all adoption of the plug-in.
I think that's always been a concern about,
you know how many people, you know plug-in's
are kind of a pain, we'd love to not have
them, we'd love it if, you know, the browsers
could do great 3D all the time. That's not
quite where we are just now, but we've had
a great adoption and penetration with Earth
API and we are now over 100 million installs
of the plug-in, which is uh, you know a very
impressive number in end user base. As developers
you're thinking about actually creating an
Earth API application that there's a, you
know, a broad base of users out there who
use it. Um, and I think that's about it.
>>Thor: Great, thank you for that. Okay, so
um, we uh, we have a wave. If you would like
to submit questions through that. We also
have a microphone. Um, it's great for us,
Google IO is always a good opportunity for
us to meet developers and understand our community.
We also have a couple of other means by which
you can engage with us over the course of
the year outside of Google IO which I just
want to also remind you of. It's always really
helpful for us to hear from developers. All
of the products on stage here and many other
Google APIs have a dedicated Google group,
and many of us spend time reading posts on
that, responding to posts on those groups.
There are a number for the Maps API and for
other APIs, so I'd encourage you to take a
look at those, join them. They are a fantastic
repository of information about, about these
APIs. We also have a issue tracker on code.Google.com,
which is a place where you as a developer
can go and report any problems you are having
with the API, or make suggestions for features
you might like to see introduced in the API.
And, in addition, you can see what problems
or features other people have reported and
essentially vote on those features by starring
them. And if you do that, you'll be notified
of any updates that occur on those issues,
and it also helps us to understand the demand
for various features and we take that very
seriously and we do listen to that. That having
been said, um, I was looking on Maps API issue
tracker today, and there's one feature on
there that is dramatically way out in front
in terms of it's, the demand for it, so what
do you think? Any idea what that is?
>>Ben: Uh the redirections, right?
>>Thor: Yeah, a web service for driving directions.
So, it doesn't sound hard.
>>Ben: Well, we already have it for JavaScript’s,
so we could probably write that tonight.
>>Thor: Yeah? Done by the end of the day?
>>Ben: Yeah.
>>Thor: All right. Done by the end of the
day. So, there we go. If you uh, if you have
a similar, similar idea that you'd like to
see us implement, just pop it on there and
then get your friends around and have them
star it, then you never know, we might just,
we might just make it happen. So, with that,
um, I'll open up to questions. [pause] [Thor
makes ticking noises with tongue] Yay.
>>Audience Male 1: I don't know if this is
a question for you guys or not but I'll give
it a shot. I work at an environmental non-profit
across the bay here and uh, we use Google
Maps API, um, to display environmental data
with great background imagery and so forth
that you guys provide. At one time in the
past, you know we had our own [imagery] server
and we putting our own government imagery
up and doing it all ourselves. But, it's been
wonderful to be able to use Google Maps API
for those kind of things. And in talking to
my director, you know, we'll talk and I'll
say yeah look, look at what we can do here
and the different, you know we can have terrain,
we can have satellite imagery and so on and
so forth. And he's like wow, this is, this
is all free! Yes, this is all free. Um, is
it always going to be free? You know, how,
how many eggs should we put into this basket,
you know there's always that kind of background
concern that um, you know what, how many eggs
should we put into the Google Maps API basket.
Um, is there anything you guys could say that
would, in my next conversation with my director
to say don't worry or?
>>Thor: So if you're worrying about it being
free, you're welcome to pay for it. [Laughter].
Um, uh we have a product called Maps, Google
Maps API Premier. And Google Maps API Premier
is essentially the existing Google Maps API,
but with a bunch of other considerations wrapped
around it, are wrapped around it for these
sort of situations. Um, one that's particularly
pertinent here is that when you purchase Google
Maps API Premier, obviously you purchase a
one, or two, or three year license and in
doing so, you know, we commit to you this
service will continue to exist and continue
to be maintained and supported for that period
of time. On top of that, you get access to
technical support, you get a service level
agreement, you get a few additional features,
such as access to the API over https. Your
quotas for various services such as geocoding
and directions increase substantially and
you can purchase more if you need to. Um,
and uh, you know we have a few other things
in the pipeline, so it sounds like you, uh,
you just want to pitch that product and we'll
be really happy for you to do that.
>>Audience Male 1: Do you have any kind of
non-profit pricing at this stage?
>>Thor: Um, actually, yes. I should have mentioned
that. So if you do a search on your selection
of choice for, um, I believe it's Google Earth
Outreach and Google Maps Outreach, is that
right?
>>Peter: Earth Outreach. Go talk to him.
>>Thor: Oh, go talk to him. So yes.
>>Audience Male 1: Okay.
>>Thor: And essentially, you can apply for
a free Premier license, basically. Oh I should
also mention that the premier licenses also
have slightly modified terms of service, that
you're allowed to do some things that you
can't normally do with the Maps APIs, such
as use it in an application that you sell
for money, and use it in environments where,
internet environments or environments where
their user base is restricted in some way.
>>Audience Male 1: Thanks.
>>Audience Male 2: Hi, how are you?
>>Thor: Good.
>>Audience Male 2: Excellent. Um, I'm not
sure if this is like uh, again I'll see if
this is a Geo Team question, but do you guys
plan on opening up an IP to Geo location API?
>>Thor: Oh, this is the ability to determine
someone's location approximately based on
their IP address?
>>Audience Male 2: Yeah, I mean I know you
guys are kind of doing a lot of that under
the scenes, like similar to like a Max Mind
or a Queue Remote?
>>Thor: So, um, the, it's not part of Maps
APIs, but there is an API called the AJAX
Search API, I think, has a client location
object which can do this. Um, it's not a kind
of a paste, sort of a rest service it's just
a JS-based API but it does already exists.
So just do a search for client location, all
one word.
>>Audience Male 2: Okay
>>Thor: you'll find information about that.
>>Audience Male 2: Okay.
>>Ben: It's fairly course though, the best
we get is sort of city level, like.
>>Audience Male 2: Okay. Check. All right,
thanks.
>>Peter: So we're waiting for the uh, next
lucky questioner, um I just want to encourage
everyone who hasn't had a chance yet, to make
sure you get out to the sandbox area and check
out some of the different applications being
shown. There's a lot of great examples of
partners who are doing great things with Maps
API and Earth API and others, so if you hadn't
gotten a chance yet, I encourage you definitely,
go out there and take a look at what people
have been doing. It's really impressive.
>>Audience Male 3: [Strong Danish accent]
Hi. Can I have a question? About pricing of
Google Maps Premier edition. Because of, how
much is it, approximately, and what can you
use it for, because what we did in the past
was application for like watching cars moving
around the world. It's paid apps so we were
unable to use Google Maps; the free version.
And as we look to Premier Edition, it was
so expensive that it's like impossible to
use for a small startup, just to try for a
while. So, we had to switch to Open Layers,
unfortunately.
>>Thor: Is Dan here? No, it doesn't look like
it. There are a lot of different Google, Googler's
at the conference, as you are aware and um
many, many different people in the room and
um there are a couple of people here from
the Maps API Premier Team, including, as in
my counter part, and it might be easier for
me just to connect you with him.
I'm happy to do that afterwards. Um, I don't
believe the pricing has changed dramatically,
is all I'll say to that, right now.
>>Audience Male 3: So, uh, was it right, that
it's really so expensive that it, like, doesn't
start with some small money, and grows, but
it's very expensive from, from very beginning
for paid apps?
>>Thor: Right, so the, the difficulty right
now is that the way in which we manage Google
Maps API Premier accounts is a fairly manual
process. It's sort of, you know many of these
kind of large enterprises expect a good hands
on, you know a good customer relationship,
sort of direct access to people. And so, um,
we don't really have that middle ground right
now in terms of just automated purchasing,
at you know, which would allow us to keep
the prices down. But it's certainly something
that, you know, we're very conscious of and
that we are working on.
>>Audience Male 3: Okay, thank you.
>>Audience Male 4: So, this question may not
be relevant to you guys either, but um
[Laughter].
>>Thor: You do know what session this is,
right.
>>Audience Male 4: Yeah. I do, uh so uh we
all know the power of um, localization data,
in particular um, I'm thinking of apps like
Latitude. I'd kind of like to hear how you
guys plan on protecting that data, because
in particular, um, tying location data into
a telephone, can um, you know, open up a whole
bunch of privacy concerns. So.
>>Peter: Yeah, you might want to go try to
find the mobile folks to specifically ask
that, I mean, as a general answer, obviously
privacy is a really key part of everything
we do and in terms of the, you know, access
to that information, um, there are multiple
levels of control to make sure that, you know,
whatever information we gather is information
that you're approving of and that you can
control who has access to that. In terms of,
you know, assurance and specifics about more
detail, it's definitely out of my realm. So,
I would encourage you to track down someone
on the mobile team and Latitude team. I don't
know if Steve Lee is here or not.
>>Thor: One thing I would mention is there
is a session at, I think it's 3:00 today,
that relates, relates amongst other things,
to Latitude and there will be some Latitude
folks speaking at that session. So if you
have particular questions around Latitude
or around, sort of, the way that privacy is
managed within Latitude, um they would definitely
be the right people to talk to. Um, I think
it, you know, it's not surprise to anybody
that it's a concern that's top of our minds
and something that we're very conscious of.
>>Audience Male 5: Hi guys, this is definitely
a question for you.
[Laughter]
>>Peter: Yay.
>>Audience Male 5: [Strong Finnish accent]
But might be a bit newbie question. I have,
I'm not, I don't know about KLM or KML service
is it? Nothing but well, I'm from Finland
and I work in a non-profit organization that
collects spatial data for, for free usage
and anyone can send us data. We provide VFS,
W-V-F-S, services for it and um, we're interested
in, is it possible for us to share that data
also as a KML service, and if it is, what
would be the best way? Does it have a, some
sort of server software for it or something
like that? By the way they use POSCI database,
all the data.
>>Peter: You want to come up here? Get up
here! Why not?
[Inaudible answer from audience / off microphone]
>>Peter: We're just going to make this interactive
here, go right into the audience. Mano Marks
is one of our key KML advocates.
>>Mano Marks: Hi, um yeah, in general there
are a number of products that you can, open
source projects that you can use that would
allow you to serve things out. One that comes
to mind particularly is GeoServer, which just
allows you to take your data and push it out
in a whole range of formats; one of which
is KML. Uh so there's, there's a few other
things like that that you can use. You can
talk to myself or Christian or Josh Livni,
who's in the back, we can tell you a lot more
about that. That's if you're wanting to do
sort of live stuff. If you want to just do
data conversion, it's a whole, there's even
a broader range of things it can use.
>>Audience Male 5: Live stuff was the thing
that we're looking for.
>>Mano Marks: Live stuff, so GeoServer's a
really good thing, or you can create your
own service, using something like Go GR, which
is another open source project.
>>Audience Male 5: Thank you.
>>Matt: A couple of things I'll add too is
that we have a Google Earth gallery, which
is if you have some interesting KMLs that
you'd like to share with other Google Earth
users, we have an Earth Gallery website, and
there's an interface there for you to actually
upload a KML and you know assign it a category
and then people can, you know, star it, a
lot of people can find it and download it.
And then finally also the Maps Data API. If
you already kind of have data in KML, uh,
that's the format that we use to upload features
to the Maps Data API so depending on what
you are trying to do, you can take a KML and
essentially upload it to Google's Cloud and
then you'll have API access to search over
it, or you know, retrieve it on different
devices. We have different client libraries
to let you kind of access it in lots of different
languages so, that's another possibility.
>>Audience Male 5: What if you have websites
that will generate KMLs in response to user
choices, say from the census or some other
government-based data or public data? In other
words, putting up a, I wouldn't be putting
up a KML, I'd be putting up a service, that,
you know that's free and open and all that.
>>Peter: Yeah, so from a service standpoint,
you can always use a network link, right so
there's a couple of different ways.
>>Audience Male 5: So I could put a link up.
>>Peter: To get information. Right, so one
is if you have your own site you can always
host your own data and make it available.
You can either visualize it in situ with either
Google Maps or Google Earth API. If you want
to have, say a download that is a static file
but generated based on user input, you could
have your own forum and submit that to your
server and have it produce back a static KML
and then, finally, if you want to have something
that's truly dynamic, you could have just
a network link that refreshes, and potentially
you could have different flavors of network
links based on different parameters and then
users could download that, and that will continually
query the server. And there's a lot of things
within KML that allows you to, you know, using
regions and other triggering mechanisms to
you know, sort of an alternate to a WMS kind
of a server.
>>Audience Male 6. I have a very specific
geeky kind of question. Um, I do a lot in
Flex and I was wondering what is the preferred
swick for KML parsing? I currently use Google
Maps API utility library 426 2009.
[Laughter] [inaudible comment from audience]
>>Audience Male 6: The reason I ask is that
particularly, if you got out utility library
now, it just says it's been deprecated, but
I don't know where to go from there.
>>Thor: Is this the Google Maps utility library
specifically for Flex?
>>Audience Male 6: Yeah.
>>Thor: Or is it that that particular library
in the utility library has been deprecated.
>>Audience Male 6:. It's, it's the API utility
library for KML parsing that you had up for
Flex.
>>Thor: Okay, um off the top of my head, I'm
not sure but um, if you come and grab me afterwards,
we'll take a look and we'll figure it out.
>>Audience Male 6: Okay.
>>Audience Male 7: Hi, I guess I have a similar
question um, it's about the Earth API utility
library. So it's the JavaScript utility library
for the Earth API. Um, is that still being
like worked on? Like it's in version 0.2 or
something like that? Is there any, are there
any plan to add to that or anything like that?
Peter. So that's a good question. So the question's
about the Earth utility library, um and a
lot of that work was actually done by Roman
Nurik who was our developer advocate. He's
actually now working on, on Android. Um, so
I think it's an open question and I think
part of it is based on feedback in terms of
what would be useful to developers, right?
And as we think about new API, there's always
a question of should this live, you know in,
within the plug in as an API or does it make
more sense for us to put a lower level API
in and then include some code in the utility
library. So I think that that utility library
is something that's always an option for us
that if we feel like, you know, this is code
that's useful, but probably doesn't make sense
to live within the, you know, the plug-in
itself, um then, you know we absolutely would
want to do that. I don't know Thatch if have
any more? Yeah and then Josh who's back over
here is the guy who's probably going to write
anything that if uh, [laughs] so um, if you
have any specific suggestions or things where
it's like hey, I you know, I'm, I really wanna
be able to do this one function and it's a
real, you know inconvenience for me, or I
have a great piece of code that I think, you
know would be great to share out with other
developers, um Josh is your man.
>>Audience Male 7: OK, thanks.
>>Thor: I just want to um take I'm sorry I
don't want to keep you standing around too
long, but um I just want to take a couple,
one of the, one or two of the questions off
of Google wave as well while we're here. So,
we'll just take one right now. Um, one of
the questions I can see on there relates to
um, the correct way to add or modify building
labels on Google Maps. I think this is specifically
relating to cases where the, uh the information
on the base map is, is, is incorrect. Matt,
do you want to speak to that?
>>Matt: Uh sure, so what you'd like to do,
so there's actually two questions there; one
is about how to change building labels and
the example here is case Western Reserve University
I think has some missing building labels they're
saying. And the other is about, you know uh,
sidewalks or paths being not quite right so
if you, in general, when you notice things
on, uh, Google Maps, um in the U.S, there's
a small link in the bottom right corner that
says report a problem, and you can go there
and it lets you report a problem, say about
a street or an address that might be wrong,
something that's missing, a label in the wrong
place, and you can select a number of options
and kind of move the little marker near where
the problem is occurring and you know, our
turn around time is generally pretty good
so we're able to kind of review those and
determine what needs to be fixed and we are
actively fixing things, um, you know, all
the time, so that's, the bottom right corner
you'll see a little report a problem link
and that's the recommended way to do it.
>>Audience Male 8: Hi, I have a question about
a aerial oblique imagery. Um, I wonder what
you can tell me about it's appearance and
growth in V3? Uh, I think it's not available
in V3 now. Hoping to see it some day. I wonder
what's in between aerial and other higher
priority features that I would expect to see
before that, and also just the acquisition
of more imagery; anything you can tell me
at all, maybe nothing.
>>Thor: So back in January we posted a roadmap
for V3 on the on the Google group. Um, and
it basically laid out all the features that
we planned to introduce in V3, um at that
point, and we've now ticked off every one
of those features, with the exception of aerial
imagery. Uh, the um, we basically just had
to decide, we had to prioritize essentially
based on what we could see the, the usage
was in V2. That was the approach we took,
so, in, in order to um, be able to graduate
the Maps API V3, we felt we needed to reach
a certain level of, you know a sufficient
level of feature parity with V2 that the majority
of V2 applications would be able to migrate
to V3. And, uh as you probably know, aerial
imagery has not, is not um, is not being used
in a lot of API sites yet, for a number of
reasons. Coverage is, is clearly one of them.
Discoverability is another. And also, just
general awareness of the feature, you know
to a large extent, the Maps API has relied
in the past on feature awareness being driven
by the Google Maps application rather than
you know on the Maps API itself, so as aerial
imagery isn't currently launched on Google
Maps, I think a lot of developers don't realize
we have it in the API. So the decision we
came to essentially was that we needed to
um, focus on Street View first, because Street
View is definitely uh leading on...
>>Audience Male 8. [Talks over Thor] It's
a good choice.
>>Thor: [continues] many API sites. And Street
View was a fairly challenging um feature,
because uh in V2 and on Google Maps it has
a dependency on flash and the Maps API V3
is, you know has been pitched from the start
and was motivated by the desire to cater better
to mobile devices, many of which don't support
flash right now. So, um, we knew that was
a big challenge and one we needed to just
crack on with and that we would revisit aerial
once that was done. We didn't think it was
necessary to have aerial ready before we graduated
because of the low levels of use. And we're
also keen to see um, it's probably no great
surprise that there are discussions going
on about, you know ways of bringing aerial
to Google Maps as well and how that might
be done um, and uh you know we want to make
sure that we, we are, that the implementation
and the API is consistent with whatever happens
there. So, um the short answer is it's on
the roadmap. We've committed to doing it in
writing, it's got my name on it and I've sworn
in blood that we will do this, um, but uh,
I can't give you a commitment right now as
to exactly when that might happen.
>>Audience Male 8.: Did I hear in that the
sort of well, I'm not even really sure if
aerial matters all that much? That, it seems
like, oh, you know we're not really using
it, people aren't consuming it.
>>Thor: No. You did not hear that.
[Laughter]
>>Audience Male 8: Oh, fine
>>Thor: I mean, let me expand on that. No,
I do think it's very useful, and I know that
um, you know, in the places where we have
it, it's certainly much, much easier to orientate
yourself within that environment, particularly
if you know it well, when you have the aerial
imagery. Um, and you know we just need to
have, you know a reasonably comprehensive
level of coverage and we need to have a good
user experience such that users know it's
there, understand how to integrate with it.
Also, um, do not get disorientated by it as
they switch in and out of aerial imagery which
is rotatable compared to non-aerial imagery,
which is not. So it's actually a fairly complex
UI problem as well to do right. Um, but if
we can get it right, I think it will be very
compelling. And I think it, it's also worth
saying that it bridges the gap very well between
the Maps, the Street View and also Earth as
well.
>>Matt: I think for the Real Estate in this
case in particular I think it's really compelling
if I'm looking for apartments, or looking
for a house if you don't want to see the obliques
it kind of adds a lot so you can kind of get
a sense of what's it's. Okay. [laughter].
That's kind of how I think about it.
>>Audience Male 8: And if you can say anything
at all about coverage, how it may expand.
Maybe not.
>>Thor: Um, none of, none of the people here
are really you know heavily involved in the
collection side of things. Um, you know coverage
is clearly important and uh we continue to,
to acquire, you know, more imagery, there
is a you know, a processing delay involved
in the, in getting that imagery into shape
and suitable for use, but all I can say is,
you know that effort continues and you know
we hope to see more and more coverage. One
thing, um, that um, that is also a bit of
a problem right now is that it's not completely
clear where the coverage is and, and as new
coverage comes online, you know we try and
post to the group about it or something like
that. But it often gets sort of lost in the
noise and so um, you know we need to do a
better job of discoverability generally, I
think.
>>Audience Male 8: Thank you.
>>Peter: While we wait for the next question,
whoever had the question about Maps API Premier
pricing, Dan Chu is now in the house.
>>Thor: Wave Dan.
>>Peter: Raise your hand. So uh, if you can
track down Dan afterwards he'll be happy to
answer all of your Maps API Premier questions.
>>Audience Male 9: [Strong eastern European
accent] Okay, my question is in V3 for Maps,
are we able to have all our layers a complex
KML that we exported to Google Earth? You
know with all the polygons, lines and see
a different altitudes? Are we going to be
able to get that experience with a 2D except
for the third dimension? Load, you know, complex
super-overlays into maps without having to
do any tweaks and just use the same KML or
the network link.
>>Ben: So we support markers, polylines, polygons
and large numbers of markers and polylines
and polygons as well as complex polylines
and polygons. We, the parser for the KML in
maps is a different parser, Google Apps parser.
There is some old KML that does not make the
KML spec that you might need to modify a little
bit. But there are schema checkers that will
help you find the bugs.
>>Peter: Okay, so I'll add a little bit to
that too. So, I mean, it's a known issue that
what is viewable within Maps, from a KML standpoint
is not on par with what's viewable within
Earth and that's a known issue and we know
that's a pain point for developers. You know,
things are a little bit better now in the
sense that you can have you know Earth API
and be able to view a full KML in that context,
but that's still not a, a complete answer.
So um, a lot has improved, you know, since
last year in terms of what our maps based
KML parser can do, in terms of what it will
accept. Um, it's a, you know, taken many steps
forward from before when it would not even
be able to parse certain types of things.
But we still have work to do. So, we're continuing
to work on that and trying to kind of bring
that up to a level where it will be able to
uh, understand and accurately render uh, the
full set of KML.
>>Audience Male 9: And it's able to, if I
have a network link to my super-overlays on
my server, it's able to respect all the conditions
for when to show layer at which altitude and
turn off, turn on all those things?
>>Peter: So again, at the moment, um, not
everything is supported. So network links
are supported. Super-overlays I believe are
sort of iffy. Um, you know and again if there's
a specific question you have about some feature,
you can come and talk to myself or Mano or
some of the other folks over here. But, but
there definitely will be things you can find
that will not behave in the same manner and,
and, we know about that and we still have
work to do there.
>>Matt: There's a pretty helpful table on
one of the help sites. I'm not sure which,
if you, it kind of shows exactly what subset
of KML is currently supported and that's been
growing over time. But if you wanna know exactly
which features are supported or not there's
a table, and I can help you find it afterward
if you want.
>>Thor: It's uh, it's linked from one of the
FAQs on the Maps API documentation, so if
you just look for the Maps API FAQ and there's
a FAQ in there along the lines of what features
are supported for KML.
[Mano - off microphone / inaudible comment
to questioner]
>>Thor: Yeah, as I mentioned earlier, definitely
um, you know, the issue tracker is there for
a reason and we do take it seriously, so um,
so please do, do use it. Um, on that subject
actually there's a related question on the
wave, which is how can I make my own tile
layer, like a Wikipedia layer. I have the
tiles, but how can I make the points on the
tiles clickable? Um, so.
>>Peter: What was the question? I'm sorry,
I can't understand your accent so.
>>Thor: [laughter] The question,
>>Peter: I'm just gonna walk over here.
>>Thor: Yeah, you do that.
>>Peter: I have this technology.
>>Thor: Is the rest of the room not understanding
me? Am I just, you know. [laughs] Okay, good.
>>Peter: How can I make the points on the
tiles clickable?
>>Thor: Yeah.
>>Peter: [reading to himself quietly] Ah how
can I make my one tile layer...[into microphone
now] Um so is this a question about Earth
API or Maps API?
>>Thor: I think it's, it relates to the Maps,
so in the maps API V2 we have, um, a couple
of layers that overlay icons that tell you
whether they're related to Wikipedia articles
or icons that tell you whether they're related
panoramia photos and those icons, you can
click on them and info windows arrive. But
I was thinking that KML might be a good solution
to this.
>>Peter: Yeah, so there's really, in general
there's two solutions. One is you have KML,
in which case the content associated with
the balloon is encapsulated in the data. And
so, when you click on it then the info window
is displayed. The other option is to use an
event, a click event so if you just want to
display a marker on the map and you get a
click event and then do something based on
that.
>>Audience Male 10: I didn't write that question,
but do you think maybe they're asking about
kind of like, kind of like when you can choose
your layers, or when you can choose like your
tile layers like, I think there's like a Wikipedia
click like show it or not show it. Is that
what, maybe that's what they're asking?
>>Thor: I think, I think the core of the question
is that if you have a very, very large number
of points you want to render on a map, there
comes a point where your browser begins to
struggle. And the recommended solution to
this is to render a tile set that has those
point on. That works very well, except that
those tiles are not, the individual points
are no longer clickable because they're just
imagery tiles. Um, and uh, so um, you know
the, the person who wrote this question has
noticed that we return imagery tiles for the
Wikipedia layers and the panoramia layers
and yet somehow they're also clickable. So
I think the question is how, how can you do
that? Um, and uh there are a couple of things
I can think of. One is the service that serves
up these clickable layers is also, can, it's
the same service we use for KML rendering
in V3, so if you have, if you can represent
this data as a KML file rather than rendering
your own tiles, then you can attach descriptions
to each object which will appear in the info
windows when they're clicked. Um, if you are
worried about serving up a large KML file,
then you can upload that data to the maps
data API and it can be served from there very,
very quickly as well.
>>Matt: So, for example, if you have 10,000
points, you know you can just render what's
in the info window but you can say just give
me back what's in this bounding box and every
time I pan my my map, you know give me you
know it's, it's very fast so you can, it will
return the new results in the bounty box and
see if you can get those nice corian pan effect,
which is this very large data sent, but you're
only having to render sort of what's in the
bounding box.
>>Audience Male 10: Um, well the question
I was going to ask was uh, regarding to the
uh, the Geocoding. Uh, can you give, can you
give some insight on, kind of the roadmap
for like what new countries are going to be
supported and kind of, or insight into like
how process improvement of accuracy of Geocoding
as that evolves. Like if I have an address
at like, are you guys improving the existing
countries?
>>Thor: So, um, so the Geocoder essentially
relies on the same data set from which we
render the base map tiles. Um, and uh this
is obviously deliberate so that everything's
consistent and in sync. And we're constantly
acquiring new data. Um, and we're also constantly
collecting corrections and refinements to
our existing data, both from users and from
other, other places. Um, so coverage is, you
know, it's also obviously important to us,
and we are always looking to, to extend our
coverage for a number of different means,
sometimes we, we find data that we can license
for a particular area that we don't have good
coverage, but also we have Map Maker now,
which um, is, has rolled out in a number of
countries you can probably.
>>Matt: The total number of 100 something
countries, that's a lot of countries.
>>Thor: Yeah, um and Map Maker has proved
very useful in countries where we don't have
any existing data or limited data sets, um
and there are some fascinating videos on YouTube
of the way in which the maps for those regions
have evolved rapidly as a result of launch
of Map Maker, which essentially allows you
to actually draw roads and features and such
like on the map. So, um, I mean I can't comment
specifically on, you know we expect to get
more data here and here and here. Um, but
we're not done in improving our data and never
will be.
>>Matt: I'd also encourage everyone to you
know take an active role in fixing things
that you see are wrong I mean a lot of people,
you know a lot of times you're the local experts,
really, you know you neighborhoods better
than we do and so on Google Maps a lot of
people don't realize you can actually fix
problems that you see so if you call a phone
number and you find out that a place is closed
or that something is, you know a phone number's
changed, you can actually say a place page,
there a link at this place and you can go
in and you can you know, update the phone
number, fix a bad category, you can drag the
marker, if the marker seems to be in the wrong
location. And, uh, or if you don't know there's
a problem you can just, there's a way to report
a problem. So maybe you found the phone number
is wrong, you're not really sure what the
right phone number is you can just essentially
say, hey Google this phone number's wrong
and write us a little comment. And then we'll
sort of look into the details and figure out
what the phone number should be so you know,
we really would like to kind of empower users
to be the experts for their, their neighborhoods
and help us kind of fix problems that they
find.
>>Audience Male 11: So uh, first of all thank
you for the work that you do. I know my livelihood
is at least partially dependent on your success,
so well done, thank you. My question is uh,
in regards to the elevation service, um which
is awesome. Uh, are you thinking about expanding
it in any way? I have two specific applications.
One; can I request elevation for an area instead
of just along a line or a path? And two, something
that would really benefit from the computing
power that you guys have in the cloud is given
a point and an area around it, calculate a
view shed? Like what can I see, you know what
you know uh, make mountains or whatever or
impeding the line of sight and maybe supplement
the line of sight algorithm with an RF line
of sight, for instance, and that would definitely
[not be me 40:18], but um even just a view
shed would be, would be useful for that application
so, this is just an expansion of the elevation
service, I guess.
>>Thor: So, do you want an answer to the first
part of the question, what are our plans for
the service?
>>Audience Male 11: Yes.
>>Thor: I would say um we don't have any,
any immediate plans for kind of dramatic changes
to the service. The one thing that we have
been asked for that we're looking into is
a way of obtaining um, information about the
accuracy of the underlying data or at least
sort of the granularity I suppose is a better
word, for the underlying data in other words
what the sampling, base sampling distance
was.
>>Audience Male 11: Is it DTED or SRTM data
that you're using?
>>Thor: Um I it varies, yeah it's, it's. As
with many Google services, we'll license data
from wherever we can and obtain data any way
we can and then you know we'll figure out
a way to blend it all together and make it
seamless. Um, so that's something that we
are looking into. Um in terms of sort of new
features we could build on top of that, uh
you know we're certainly open to ideas and
you know again I suggest you put them on the
issue tracker. Um, what we tend to find a
lot on the issue tracker is that we get a
lot of requests for, you know you have feature
X in API A can we have it in API B? Um, and
uh and such like. It would be great to have
more kind of, you know ideas that genuinely
novel. Exactly, yes.
>>Audience Male 11: Okay. Thank you.
>>Audience Female: Hi, so um, I'm one of the
organizers of the new National Robotics Week
in the US and we've been trying to use Google
Maps to show affiliated events across the
country. For the first year we kind of had
a really hackie solution that went through
like a Yahoo pipe and it didn't work very
well. So if you guys can you give me any suggestions
in terms of how to integrate a Google calendar
and get that onto a Google Map I'd appreciate
it.
[group discussion on stage / off mic]
>>Matt: So Google has a family of API's called
the GData; the Google Data APIs or GData for
short. Um and you know, so calendar, um you
know, contacts, like Maps Data API is an example
of one of these, so I would imagine you can
kind of pull information out from calendar
through the GData API and then render it using
the Maps API on the map, but um.
>>Thor: It's also worth mentioning that um
you know in the last year our primary focus
in the Maps team at least has been to work
on V3 and uh bring V3 up to scratch. Um, but
now that we've graduated obviously we have
an opportunity now to start doing some new
and interesting things and one of the things
that's particularly interesting to me personally
um that I think that we haven't done necessarily
as good a job of in the past as I would have
liked is improving the ease with which you
can integrate the Maps API with other services
that Google offers. Um, so that's something
that I think we'll be taking a more active
interest in trying to help people to do. Google
has a lot of fantastic things to offer um,
and you know it's one of our, the strengths
that we have and so, you know I'd like to
see us make more of that.
>>Audience Female: Great. Thank you very much.
>>Audience Male 12: Hi guys. Our company has
a number of Google Earth pro licenses and
uh we have managers using these tools in order
to contribute place marks and data and we
collect all those KMLs and then we apply tool
sets in Google Maps. There's, there's two
issues that I have, and they've been ongoing
for about two to three years now, um since
we've purchased the pro licenses. Number one
was when we used the import function to import
spreadsheets, we find that sometimes the,
when it comes to the Geocoding, the uh the
addresses aren't correctly Geocoded because
there's issues with um the array. So, it spits
out a report, a little square that says, please
validate these, these addresses. I can't copy
and paste that list, I can't even save that
list, I can't then save that list separately
so that I can go through and uh manually validate
it. What's the story there?
>>Peter: So, um, couple things. A question
about uh Earth Pro and some of the import
capabilities in there. Um, so one this is
we are working on making some improvements,
um to the overall import capabilities of the
product. In terms of the specifics of the
Geocoder, um I would probably need to look
to see, I mean especially if you have a sample
file or something, um come talk to me afterwards,
I'd love to kind of get a little bit more
into the specifics of what some of those issues
might be, um because we're using the same
Geocoding service, so um, I don't know of
exactly what error you might be running into,
but I'd like to see what, what case you have
and see what we can do to improve it.
>>Audience Male 12: No worries. And a follow
up to that was using a style template function
in Google Earth Pro as well, um when we save
KML files and we try to open them in version
two of Google Maps um, it doesn't work. They're
all grouped and I take it there must be some
sort of issue with style template. Given that
our organization and we have literally hundreds
of people using these tools, um, that's a
pretty significant issue. Can you talk about
style template and compatibility between Earth
and Maps?
>>Peter: So, I don't know but my guess would
be due to the fact that the current version
of Earth Pro at exporting in schema data and
that isn't understood by Maps. That problems
will be addressed shortly. So, there are some
known issues with basically the version of
KML that Earth writes out in, which is a valid
version of KML but it's an older format that
isn't understood by the Maps adjuster, um
so there's a couple of ways of addressing
that. One is to make sure the maps adjuster
can understand all previous versions and the
other one is to write out in the most recent
version, so we're definitely working on addressing
that.
>>Audience Male 12: So does that mean that
I need to, because we're doing maps development
alongside Earth, uh that I need to switch
to V3 with Maps in order for this uh when
this function is correct or will you be changing
Earth?
Peter. Um, we're going to change Earth so
that it outputs in extended data.
>>Audience Male 12: Okay. Thank you.
>>Audience Male 13: [French accent] Hi, two
really quick questions. The first one. There
was a question about elevation, do you guys
plan to add elevation services to Google maps,
so basically height. And the second question
would be um with Android and you know Smart
Phones there was all these new sensors like
those like pressure sensors and all the old
type of sensor; do you plan to actually add
or use these sensors for Google Maps and localization
and so on?
>>Thor. Sorry, I didn't catch the last part
of the question? What type of sensor?
>>Audience Male 13: A pressure sensor, like
altimeter.
>>Thor: Oh, I see, so I think the, the um,
the main technical restriction there is exactly,
you know which sensors are exposed to the
browser or to application running in the browser.
So now, you know there is a um, a W3C Standard
for example for GeoLocation, um which includes
both position and um heading, if you like,
and we see on the GeoLocation side the location
based side of that implemented fairly well
now and the headings support is coming along,
so you know, we'll add that. I think inevitably
there's going to be a continued expansion
in the capabilities of those phones. And as
that happens, the various sort of web standards
will follow. And as they do, you know we can
look into integrating them. Um, one thing
I would say though is we don't currently want
to go too far down the road of sort of wrapping
existing standards based APIs in a thin Google
Maps API layer. We understand that there are
um, for example, lets take GeoLocation. You
know we understand that there is a benefit
for us for example, for providing a GeoLocation
class in the Maps API because you'll see it
in the Maps API documentation. It'll be front
and center, but, on the other hand, if the
W3C GeoLocation API, it's very well established,
it's well documented um and it works across
devices and, to an extent, we want to encourage
people to be familiar with these standards
and build applications that rely on them and
we want to be delivering new additional value
rather than just you know um, essentially
putting our name on an existing service. So
I, you know I would hope that those sensors
become available to other applications more
broadly and as soon as they do, you know any,
any existing Maps API application will be
able to use them.
>>Audience Male 13: Okay, thank you.
>>Ben: I would add to that. The GeoLocation
API, the W3C GeoLocation API includes altitude,
so were you able to use that?
>>Audience Male 13: Yeah, okay, so you are
not pushing to use new sensors so you basically
wait for the phones and the services to provide
it and then, okay, understood.
>>Ben: Okay, yep.
>>Thor: So, we're out of time, I think it's
only fair we have one more question from the
floor and one more question from the wave.
Can I get away with that? Okay, I'm not being
told I can't so let's do that.
>>Audience Male 12: Okay so I was just looking
at the Google Earth Application on the Android
phones that we got and I just noticed that
you can't like open KML files or like read
that in, are there any plans to update that
to uh support that?
>>Peter: Um, so the question is about Earth
on Android and you can't open KML files right
now. Um, so if you've actually used Earth
on iPhone, you'll notice that you can actually
go into My Maps and view documents that you
might have uploaded.
>>Matt: Using the Maps Data API.
>>Peter: Using the Maps Data API actually
or a customer Maps Data API. Um that, so the
same engine is running on both, so um you
might imagine that at some point in the near
future we'll be adding capability like that.
So it's, it's really just a matter of, you
know as we've been developing for Android,
we wanted to get the engine up and running
and get the basic application, but I think
you'll see, over time, across all of the mobile
space that we're going to be continuing to
invest in and grow the capabilities of you
know Earth and Maps on those coz the mobile
space is uh, obviously a very critical part
to us.
>>Thor: So, um, to wrap up, one last question
from the wave. There is a question here which
is how can I integrate Google Maps API with
ESRI's ArcGIS software? So, ESRI do actually
publish a um, a class four displaying overlays
generated by ESRI or by ArcGIS on Google Maps
API Maps. If you do a search for ArcGIS ESRI
Google JavaScript’s Maps API um, you will
find that they have a class that does support
this and various examples as well. Um, so
I think that's all we have time for. Um, we'll
uh, I certainly I think most of us will be
here the rest of the day and tomorrow as well.
So, if you see us, please feel free to come
and say Hi, and if you have any questions
we'll be happy to help you. Um, I don't want
to, to um squat in this room too long, I know
there's another session to follow, so we'll
probably move outside fairly quickly, but
we'll mill around and uh be happy to discuss
more. So thank you very much.
>>Matt: Thanks for coming.